as we mentioned earlier we have been
down this path before with North Korea
promises made and broken hopes raised
and then dashed of course mine and
Gillian Turner has a history lesson for
us tonight
Rocketman is on a suicide mission for
himself and for his regime when
President Trump faces Kim jong-un across
the negotiating table
he'll come face-to-face with North
Korea's sketchy decades long track
record of lying to the United States and
the entire international community John
yang has been striking deals with the US
and reneging on them since 1994 when the
Clinton administration established the
joint framework agreement meant to end
North Korea's nuclear ambitions once and
for all North Korea will freeze and then
dismantle its nuclear program South
Korea and our other allies will be
better protected four billion dollars in
US aid and multiple special envoys later
that agreement collapsed in 2002 when
President Bush concluded the north
wasn't living up to its agreement North
Korea is a regime arming with missiles
and weapons of mass destruction while
starving his citizens later that year
the North Koreans formally withdrew from
the non-proliferation treaty in 2003
they reopened their nuclear facilities
and three years later they conducted
their first-ever nuclear weapons test
President Obama entered office in 2009
with a lot of hope but very little
chance of bringing the rogue regime back
into the fold of the international
community North Korea and its people
have a choice they can choose to
continue down a lonely road of isolation
or they can choose to join the rest of
the world by the end of President
Obama's first year in office Pyongyang
had declared it was no longer bound by
any of the terms it had ever agreed to
in the past now President Trump faces a
choice of his own Brett Julian thank you